[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida feliz mañana para ti
vamos a hablar de una nueva terapia que
permitió que pacientes con lesiones
medulares severas volverán a combinar
una muy buena noticia amar pues sí de
hecho es una terapia bien innovadora
pero que no deja de ser el resultado de
años de investigación ayer explicábamos
además que era la primera vez que se
lograba que personas con la médula
completamente lesionada sin ningún tipo
de movimiento residual pudieran volver a
andar para explicar mejor de qué se
trata todo esto cómo funciona qué
impacto puede tener estamos con sergio
daniel hernández neuro ingeniero del
instituto federal de tecnología en los
dan en suiza uno de los autores del
estudio que se ha publicado con los
resultados de esta terapia y de varios
equipos de los equipos que han
desarrollado esta hazaña doctor muy
buenos muy buenos días y gracias por
acompañarnos hoy creo que es mejor que
nada que escuchemos desde sus propias
palabras en qué consiste esta nueva
terapia
buenos días
esta terapia
pues hay que entender que nuestro
cerebro envía señales y controla
nuestras piernas a través de la médula
espinal cuando hay una lesión de la
médula espinal esta comunicación se ve
interrumpida
esta tecnología
intenta a través de estimulación
eléctrica unos impulsos de 40 a 100
veces por segundo reactivar las neuronas
que tenemos ya en la espina para poder
controlar leer las piernas no sólo
podemos controlar las piernas sino
también permite controlar las los
músculos del tronco lo cual mejora la
estabilidad de la postura y mejora la
calidad de la vida de vida de estos
pacientes que han sufrido estas lesiones
en este caso unas lesiones medular de la
médula completa
doctor gracias por sus gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros los saludos me llamo
raúl pues estoy aquí acompañando a más
romeros en esta sección de salud le
preguntó entonces si es posible que ese
tratamiento se use en el día a día de
los pacientes o todavía falta para esto
doctor
es cabe decir que esta tecnología va de
la mano con sesiones de terapia muy
intensas alrededor de 6 meses pero luego
esta tecnología es bastante portátil
los pacientes pueden
utilizarlas en actividades como
bicicleta nadar o incluso boxear
es muy importante mencionar que esto no
es una cura pero es un paso muy
importante para mejorar los síntomas y
permitir a estos pacientes recordar una
autonomía claro digamos que por ahora
también estamos hablando de mejoras muy
significativas en la calidad de vida de
estas personas porque imagino que
también pues pueden fortalecer sus
músculos de otras formas que antes no
hacían bueno estos resultados son
después de muchos años de investigación
en el 2014 se hizo con ratas en 2016 con
monos 2018 se consiguió con un paciente
que no tenía la médula completamente
dañada hemos llegado al final de estas
de estas progresiones o todavía hay más
pasos a dar
está muy bien que lo menciones es el
resultado de más de 15 años de
investigación
aún
falta falta investigarlo en una
población más más grande en 50 100
pacientes para lograr entender los
efectos
ya en una población más grande
y este esperamos pues es sólo un paso
más hacia lograr mejorar la calidad de
vida de estos pacientes de lesión de la
médula espinal y vamos a seguir
trabajando en ello para lograr tener un
gran impacto
en ellos ahora doctor esos pacientes no
tenían ni movimiento y tampoco
sensibilidad le pregunté entonces si
ellos recuperaron el movimiento y
también recordaron algo de sensibilidad
sí
es bueno que lo menciones pero es cuando
el sistema está en sentido sin el
sistema
toca mencionar que las sensaciones
también se van
claro tengo una última pregunta y es que
esta terapia está personalizada a un
máximo nivel no estudiaron perfectamente
dónde colocar estos implantes de estos
electrodos esto dificulta que luego pues
se extienda a la población en general
que llegue a más pacientes del hecho de
que sea tan personalizada
pues esperamos lograr llegar a más
pacientes lo que hemos observado es la
personalización contribuye al éxito de
nuestro ensayo clínico
pero esperamos poder contestar en el
futuro cuando sepamos
como a lograr
en una gran población aplicada en
nuestra tecnología
así sea doctor mi decisión gracias a ti
muchísimas gracias entonces por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24
marc también gracias por acompañarnos en
esta sección estamos conversando con
sergio en el hernández es neuro
ingeniero en youtube fuera de tecnología
en usan uno de los autores de este
estudio que permitió a estas personas
volver a caminar y sentir gracias más
gracias doctor nosotros vamos ahora a
pasar a nuestro